So let's talk a little bit about how you go about exporting and importing your FBXs and
the best pipelines to follow.
So the main rules of the skeleton are essentially the same rules apply to any skeleton setup.
You should have one root bone in your mesh or your skeleton, should we say, that connects
to everything else.
Root goes from zero zero to a central bone, e.g. a hip bone if you're using a humanoid
skeleton and this helps with root motion, which we'll talk about a little bit about
later.
Your blending is based on a fully connected skeleton, so the hierarchy is key here and
even if you're not making a humanoid character, even with a vehicle, just making sure you
follow a good hierarchy is super important here.
When we talk about floating bones in new skeletons, the best practice is when creating your skeletons
not to use inline twist bones and instead you should parent the wrist bone to them and
then creating a leaf bone.
So typically this is used with organic skeletons, but it's useful to keep in mind there.
And then also when talking about hierarchy, especially when we're talking about automotive,
it is really, really important.
So always start with that root bone, usually at the center of gravity, wherever that might
be on the automotive vehicle, for example, even if your model's pivot was built around
zero zero zero, you want to extend from the root outward.
So super important to keep in mind when talking about hierarchies and bones.
When we look at a pre-made animation pipeline, you're looking at the model, the rig and the
animations inside of your DCC app, and then you import your animations into UE5.
So we may end up with the sequencer animation tracks.
These are from baked animation assets.
They're all blended, weighted, maybe additive animations.
And then you can modify the animations either using the sub editor, which is our old method,
or edit in sequence option, which you can edit with the FK control rig or baked to control rig.
That just gives you a little bit more freedom and flexibility over your approach there.
The in-editor animation pipeline.
So you model and weigh in your DCC app.
So then whenever it comes to rigging and animating, you would actually use Unreal Engine 5 for this.
So you can use a control rig and you can build out all your animation controls here.
And it's turned on by default in Unreal Engine 5.
So if you're using any of the early access versions, just make sure you're in enable
control rig.
But from this point onwards, it will be on by default now.
So you shouldn't need to do anything to get access to control rig.
The sequence of key framing.
Control rig is animated using the level sequence.
And then you build an empty level as a work area or you can animate directly in the scene.
So we'll talk about sequence in a little bit more detail in a few slides here to give
you a better idea about what sequence there is.
When it gets to the mayor export, we can select the items we want to export inside of mayor.
So your mesh and your joint chain root.
And we can export selected.
So just file export selected and select the FBX type.
Set the file type, sorry, to FBX.
And you want to make sure the animation checkbox is there.
You want to include smooth and deforms.
Do you want to bake the animation?
So using Alembic to bake complex deformation, beyond blend shape and linear skinning.
So just a quick note here that a smooth mesh should be disabled and the smoothing groups
should be enabled.
So there's an image there of the type of properties you want to be setting just to give you an idea.
When it comes to 3ds Max, it's pretty much the same.
The Max and Mayor exporters have very few differences.
So we've included an image anyway.
But they're relatively on parity there.
And then Blender, we send it to the UE plugin.
So Epix created a plugin that allows you to export an FBX, which doesn't even include
meshes, but you can also export your rigs there.
And Epix playlist goes over installing and using the plugin, which will save you a lot
of time in your setup.
So to export your FBXs in Blender, you want to go to export and then FBX.
You want to make sure the fixed transform tickbox is applied there.
And armature, you want to disable add leaf bones.
The smoothing groups don't exist.
So auto smooth and split, apply modifiers, and then just make sure you uncheck the baked
animation.
And so you should be OK to go on the Blender from there.
So in Blender, forward is minus y.
So in Unreal, forward is actually positive x.
So you just want to make sure that your exports are set up in the right orientation here.
When you export the FBX, you want the default settings for the majority of this.
But also Shade and Auto Smooth for smoothing groups is selected there.
And you want to keep the scene model scale in mind.
So Blender defaults to a one meter per unit scale, whereas UE5 is one centimeter per unit.
So you just want to make sure.
So you're not trying to do any override scaling inside of Unreal.
You just want to make sure the units are set up correctly inside of Blender.
When we're exporting to Unreal, you need to provide the project's export settings only
once.
And it's not necessary to set the project again for subsequent export operations.
So enjoy exporting all your FBX animations.
And we'll move on to the next section.